[Music]
[Applause]
is uh JJ there all right uh oh let
Paulie wants to play the JJ Reddit game
what's JJ stand for so before we go to
him uh Paulie yeah so Dan JJ reck
everyone knows him but we've never asked
him what JJ stands for okay I'm going to
go around the room Dan you're gonna go
last okay what does JJ stand for all
right Todd Jimmy John Jimmy John like
the sandwich place no no I got it okay
knucklehead uh
Satan Jonathan James Jonathan James all
right Marvin I was gonna say Jonathan Jr
okay oh that's good that's that's where
I'm going I Paulie oh you already know
it I'm gonna
go James Jr re I'm G give you a hint the
middle name doesn't start with Jay Dam
which works well for the junior idea
let's bring in JJ reic who what's the JJ
stand
for well it actually doesn't stand for
anything it's a it's a nickname so I
have older twin sisters uh my name is
Jonathan Clay reick and when I was a
baby uh my dad called me Jay for short
and my older twin sisters they're about
five years older they said everything at
the same time as kids so people would
ask what my name was and they'd say J
Jay hey J J go get J J
literally that's and you know my first
memories like everybody else are at
three four years old and I was always JJ
and it's because of
them well it does help that you had an
unbelievable Jay when you played as well
I mean imagine if you could shot real
the real hint on this though for all the
Jonathan James spectator or uh
speculators is that there's no periods
in my name it's just 2js there's no J
period J period it's just two JS JJ
joining us on behalf of DraftKings this
the only reason why we wanted him on
just so we could clear up the uh the JJ
uh new customers can bet $5 get 150 in
bonus bets instantly did you ever have a
moment like LeBron had with ma Oka the
other night where the coaches saying
something to you in colorful
language um I I want to know kind of
because I think last time I was on the
show I dropped an F bomb so I I want to
be very careful of uh of my language
well just use fbom just don't okay so so
we were in I was playing with the
Clippers and we were in M Minnesota um
and Flip Saunders was the coach rest in
peace flip was a great guy little
backstory in 2013 in free agency I had
verbally committed to Minnesota and my
agents were going back and forth with
flip on on some like trade kickers and a
player option on the fourth year and in
the meantime uh the Clippers kind of
came in and doc said we're going to
trade bledo we got a sign in trade
scenario where we can get you so I had
this hour waiting period where I was
waiting for Donald Sterling to approve
this deal and flip took he's like screw
this guy I'm taking the deal off the
table five minutes later Kevin Martin
signs for my contract so I end up going
with LA two years later we're playing in
Minnesota and there's a foul we're on a
fast break there's a foul right in front
of their bench and flip walks out onto
the court he's damn near at the free
throw line and I turned to Josh tivan
who was also the referee that threw me
out when I spun the ball to him but I
turned to Josh tiban and I said get this
off the court and flip just
goes ballistic on me he starts calling
me every name in the book I'm not
backing down so then I start cussing at
him so Josh tees us both up and we're
then shooting free throws I'm at the
free I'm not shooting but I'm I'm like
at the block or whatever you know
offensive spot on the free throw line
and I I'm yelling at Josh I'm like Josh
I'm gonna get my money back for that one
that was uncalled for that was uncalled
for and then Josh just threw me out of
the game so I I got ejected uh from
mouting off to flip and flip mouting off
to me but did you ever revisit that
conversation with Flip Saunders oh the
next time we played them we had a good
laugh we had a good chule we had a good
chuckle about it did you feel inferior
as a team when you were in LA with the
Clippers like is does the team sense
that or the coverage there with
everybody you know talking about the
Lakers how does it feel to be a Clipper
in La well the Lakers sucked when I was
there so we didn't feel inferior as a
team we we certainly felt like the
bastard stepchild I mean that's you know
we're we're in uh at the time Staple
Center and we're the third tenant so we
get we get the third priority we don't
even get better priority than the the
Kings you know they the hockey team gets
better games than us
had to play a lot of one o'clock
Saturday afternoon games for Clippers
Nation but the coverage is still La even
even if you're better than we were at
the time we were one of the sort of the
buzzworthy teams and then uh some by our
own uh doing we became sort of a a meme
stock in some ways where because of some
playoff failures and some internal uh
turmoil we we we got talked about a ton
it didn't feel like we got less coverage
when I was there um but I I think that's
always going to be there um you know I
live in New York now I I live in
Brooklyn and like you go to a Knicks
game and it's a much different
experience than going to a Nets game uh
you know there's
there's decades and Decades of fandom
embedded into the Lakers and there's
decades and Decades of fandom embedded
into Knicks the Knicks and so I think
it's really really hard to overcome that
we're talking to JJ reck joining us on
behalf of draftking Sportsbook offering
additional promotions including new
customers who bet $5 get 150 in bonus
bets instantly I was wondering about the
uh inseason tournament and did these
teams embrace the inseason tournament
more than maybe other teams like is
there a sense of this is maybe more
important to certain teams than it is
others or am I am I overstating
something there no I I would say that
that's an overstatement to some degree I
do think in my observation towards the
end of the group play the teams that
were 0 and three probably didn't care as
much about the fourth game um I said
this leading up to that first uh weekend
that first Friday I called the Knicks at
bucks which was the first inseason
tournament game in NBA history and I
said look the you're talking about
highly competitive highly psycho
psychotic uh NBA players you don't need
to give them a reason to wake up in the
morning to compete for something this is
how the majority of them are wired and I
thought the level of play in in the
group play was outstanding I don't think
you could have asked for a better night
if you're the NBA than what we saw last
night with
Indianapolis uh just rocking they've got
the best inseason tournament Court they
had the best inseason tournament jerseys
they've got a rising Superstar and
Tyrese halberton who on his very first
TNT nationally televised game goes for
triple double hits that four-point play
that Aaron n Smith dunk at the end of
the game where you see the players on
the court celebrating you see the fans
you see halberton screaming like out of
Joy like that's what the NBA wanted with
this inseason tournament and so as good
as November was as good as the the group
play was I I thought it was
outstanding this week is going to be
even better because you've got these
quarterfinals G quarterfinal games at
home
where it it's a playoff atmosphere and
then we go to Vegas which is an event un
itself where guys are playing for
something so kudos to Adam Silva for
trying it I I'm sure there will be
tweaks in the future but you can't say
that this wasn't a success for the for
the first inseason
tournament if I said to you do your
senior thesis at Duke on the Joker and
explain how he does what he does
you know to a non-basketball
fan yeah I would uh it's a great
question I would 100% and Joker would
never agree to do do this but I would
100% find a clinical psychiatrist a
clinical psychologist I would get with a
neuros pych like I I would put some sort
of electrodes on his brain I would
figure out a way to do that because for
me when I watch him play his processing
speed is a little bit faster than
everyone else on the court the way he
anticipates how a defense is going to
rotate the way he anticipates coverages
how he sees things I mean think about
how many blind alyo passes he throws to
Aaron Gordon how many blind Aly passes
if Aaron Gordon is covered he somehow
anticipates when that alley when Aaron
Gordon's at the dunker spot when he's
covered skips it to the corner kcp gets
a wide open three like his his ability
to just see the whole floor faster than
everyone else is really what makes him
so special and I mean he's huge like he
he can sit there and tip the ball at The
Rim when he's missing bunnies and grabb
three offensive rebounds without ever
leaving the
floor but I don't know if he cares about
greatness I don't know if he cares about
Legacy I don't it it feels like this is
my job I go to my job and I do my job
really well but it it wouldn't surprise
me if like in three or four years he
just walks away and says I'm I'm going
home you know I have a couple thoughts
on that if you talk to anyone uh in the
Denver Nuggets organization I've got a
teammate there from duke who who works
in their front office and uh I know a
bunch of people in their front office
coaching staff his teammates he's an
absolute psychotic competitor
and it leads to the second point which
is I think this is all a bit Dan I think
he's putting us on I really
do I really do I the idea I love that I
love it that he goes that he goes home
for the summer and doesn't touch a
basketball and then the first week of
the season averages 30 12 and nine I on
62% shooting or whatever it was like I'm
not buying it I think it's all a bit
20 games into the season trying to
figure out and it's mandatory I ask you
about the Lakers because I thought the
offseason additions made them you know a
balanced team a deeper
team what is well give me your opinion
on the Lakers so
far yeah um LeBron obviously playing at
at an extremely high level no real
surprise there don't take it for granted
though what he's doing in in year 21 but
for me you know I I think they just need
to shoot the ball better they they
haven't shot well they've got a top 10
defense uh I think they're 24th in
offense as of today they're struggling
to score in the half court and I think a
lot of that is just them not shooting
well uh and you know hachimura has been
out for a number of games he's gonna
help
um they I I they're one of my
disappointing teams I have a B I have
like a list of disappointing teams and
then I have a list of weird teams they
don't quite qualify for weird yet but
they're they're in my list of
disappointing I thought they were going
to be much better to start the year and
they're just not there yet but they're a
good basketball team all right I'll
leave you with this um and I I wanted to
ask you this question I've asked this a
couple of times on on the show if I give
you it's a different take on the Jordan
LeBron argument if I said I'm going to
give you LeBron for at least 20 years or
I'm going to give you Michael at 13
years so you're going to be an
owner yeah you get LeBron's body of work
you get it for 20 you get Mike's for 13
what would you sign up for knowing what
the results are so far obviously with
Mike and LeBron is still
playing well it's a it's an interesting
way to frame the question and try to
trap me into saying who I think is the
goat but you know I I since I've gotten
into this role LeBron James is the best
player I played against and and I would
probably say there's two or three guys
you know Kobe being one Steph being
another um of course I played against
Shaq but that was later in his career
like Tim Duncan like I played against
some of the top 10 players of all time
LeBron's the best player I played
against um I I I I tend to go now with
with the Michael Jordan argument which
is what Michael Jordan said in an
interview uh sometime around 2002 or
2003 which is I can't compare myself to
Bill Russell I can't compare myself to
Will Chamber I didn't play against those
guys I didn't play against those guys
so there's so many things we need to put
into context whenever we make this
argument you know the four and six in
the finals well LeBron's teams some of
those teams really
overachieved you know he's playing in
the 2015 finals without Kyrie Irving
without Kevin Love made that a
competitive Series right that 2017 was
awful yes it was LeBron dragged that
team to the finals right uh you know
Michael Jordan 6 and0 you can't argue
with that Michael Jordan also played in
his prime during an era of Rapid
expansion in the NBA was the level of
competition during expansion as high as
it was let's say in 2015 to
2018 LeBron lost twice to KD and the
Warriors who I think I would put that
team up against any team of all time one
of the greatest teams of all time not
saying they're the greatest one of the
greatest I'd put them up against anybody
so I think the context matters in all
this to me they're the two greatest
players ever and I don't care which one
you like we're all biased to to to some
degree about who we like more well
Michael's a better player though I'm but
I would take LeBron's longevity I would
take 20 years I think I think there's
some arguments Dan around who was the
best basketball player player of all
time right who was the best basketball
player of all time versus who had the
best basketball career of all time
there's some arguments around that yes
yes Mike's the best player that's sort
of where the the question you asked is
framed that that sort of argument yeah
and I wasn't trying to trick you because
no I know you went to you went to Duke I
can't trick
you I was only kidding okay all good to
talk to you always good to see stiring
up how's the jumper by the way uh it's
it's pretty solid actually I'm coaching
I'm coaching my uh my third my third
grader uh and helping out with my first
graders team but really full-time four
days a week with my uh my third grader
he plays on a fourth grade travel team
and yesterday we were doing shell drill
and to help the kids understand better
we normally do it four on four I've got
the ball at the top of the key they get
into their shifts they interchange on
the weak side I make sure they're in
help side all that stuff yesterday to
make it easier for them to understand I
put a fifth defender on me and you know
just so they could kind of visualize it
a little bit better and I couldn't help
myself I I made this poor kid fall twice
and and laid it in the basket and I felt
wait wait wait you're breaking fourth
grade ankles yeah for a split second I
felt really good about myself and then
and then I was like what are you doing
man that's what your wife says what are
you doing what are you doing oh yeah um
thanks for joining us all right that's
JJ reck former uh NBA guard
shooter uh joining us on behalf of
DraftKings sports book Let's